ich kann das projekt begleitet
inselkammer um das projekt in forst
landwirtschaft und dann sind auf die geo
dass man würde ein film machen führt
mitten an 20 oder mehr kmu filme insel
kamerun
[Musik]
hat man eine familie freunde und die
familie hatte tochter carolin lutz
germanistik studiert hat in jaunde der
hauptstadt
und dann haben sie sich bisher einfluss
das schweizer mit woods scheiterte und
wo man sein ihre tochter kommen und ich
habe guten morgen gesagt und dass er ja
und ich habe ja was für ein komisches
komisch oder sucht dass man den ganzen
tag haben wir zusammen gerätetreiber
viel diskutiert
[Musik]
monatelang haben mit messenger was ich
tue sich etwas im internet präsent
kommuniziert und dann bin ich wieder
einmal aber marken projekt dann habe ich
sie wieder gerne besuchen und dann haben
wir schon über das weitere vorgehen was
man schon mal uns fragt ja dank dem dass
ich gar nicht botschafter burkina mir
dann ist visum über gut dass sie michael
natur berge und die natur männer haben
wir dann heute kennen gelernt und
entscheide getroffen
dann der nächste aufenthalt hat dann
müssen sie das ich und und niemand hörte
so schließlich wieder zurück oder
[Musik]
für mich war auch kurzzeitig städte
immer ja wir müssen noch mal diese
zeremonie machen ich war wirklich viel
neugier frisch und alles war neu für
mich und ich könnte nicht ja gut
gemischt sein oder das ist für mich
schon alles war wirklich neu schnell
schnell musste man ja diese zivil und
kirche machen und das war für mich ja
ich möchte dennoch mal
[Musik]
interessant ist die reaktion von einer
mutter wurde ich ihre zeit und das ich
bin verliebt haben und ich wieder ad hoc
city dann hat sie glück dass ich ja als
hilfsprojekt waren und ich der depot
wieder auf verbraucher und der weitsicht
zu
aber du machst das nicht wie sie ihren
weg auf und da ist die frage wie ich sie
wirklich geheim haben
[Musik]
oh je ich bin da ein bisschen peinlich
das ist nicht wenig später nicht sagen
ich weiß nicht das ist schwierig jetzt
nicht machen
das ist nicht typisch leitung
das ist nicht so ja er macht immer
konnte wurde